respectives de la prochaine élection
présidentielle depuis mai 2012
c'est à dire la date à partir de
laquelle je suis devenu président de la
république
j'ai agi avec les gouvernements de jean
marc ayrault et de manuel valls pour
redresser la france et la rendre plus
juste
aujourd'hui moment où je m'exprime les
comptes publics sont assainis la
sécurité sociale est à l' équilibre et
la dette du pays a été préservé j'ai
également voulu que notre modèle social
puisse être conforté parce que c'est
notre bien commun je les mêmes élargi
pour permettre à ces travailleurs qui
avaient commencé très tôt leur vie
professionnelle de partir plus
précocément à la retraite et j'ai fait
en sorte que à chacune et à chacun
puisse être accordée une complémentaire
santé
dans ce contexte j'ai aussi voulu placer
la france au premier rang au premier
rang de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et 7 à paris oui à paris que
l'accord historique a pu être signé et
qui est engagé le monde entier j'ai
voulu aussi que l'école dispose des
moyens indispensables
ceux là même qui lui avait été ôté dans
la période précédente
parce que l'école c'est le pilier de la
république j'ai fait avancer les
libertés le mariage a été ouvert à tous
les couples l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes a été renforcée et la
lutte contre les discriminations celle
qui blessent a été amplifiée j'ai
également moderniser notre démocratie
avec la réforme territoriale celle dont
on parlait régulièrement et qu'il
n'était jamais fait avec la fin du cumul
des mandats et avec également la
transparence que j'ai imposé à tous les
élus à commencer par moi même pour être
dans l'exemplarité
mais l'engagement majeur que j'avais
pris devant vous
c'était de faire baisser le chômage j'ai
consacré avec les gouvernements
toute mon énergie j'ai pris tous les
risques
j'ai allégé les charges des entreprises
parce que c'est la condition pour qu'il
y ait davantage d'emplois j'ai également
aidé les embauches
j'ai fait en sorte que la formation
professionn puis c'est une grande
priorité
j'ai également soutenu l'innovation et
l'industrie de demain et j'ai pris la
responsabilité de réformer le marché du
travail
les résultats arrivent plus tard que je
ne les avais annoncé j'en conviens mais
ils sont là l'investissement la
consommation
la construction repartent et depuis le
début de l'année le chômage
enfin diminue mais il reste à un niveau
trop élevé je mesure ce que cette
situation peut avoir d' insupportable
pour nos concitoyens qui vivent dans la
précarité
mes chers compatriotes le monde l'europe
la france ont traversé pendant tout mon
mandat des épreuves particulièrement
grave
j'ai engagé nos forces armées au mali en
centrafrique en irak en syrie pour
défendre nos valeurs et pour combattre
le terrorisme islamiste qui nous avait
frappés et qui nous menacent encore
frappé à paris à saint-denis à nice et
dans tant d'autres lieux en sanglantes
et dans ces circonstances
particulièrement éprouvante terrible
même j'ai voulu que soit maintenue la
cohésion nationale que nous puissions
éviter les divisions des surenchères les
stigmatisations et donc les amalgames
mais en même temps nous avons tenu bon
et j'ai pris les mesures qui étaient
nécessaires notre arsenal pénal a été
durcie sans mettre en cause à aucun
moment nos libertés j'ai également
procédé à des recrutements massifs dans
nos armées à la gendarmerie de la police
parce que
nous en avons besoin et qu'il y a encore
beaucoup à faire sur les réfugiés
j'ai tenu à ce que la france puisse
prendre sa part parce que nous sommes la
france dans l'accueil de ceux qui
fuyaient la guerre et qu'en même temps
nous puissions toujours maîtrisé nos
frontières sur tous ces sujets je n'ai
qu'un seul regret je veux ici l'exprimer
c'est d'avoir proposé la déchéance de
nationalité
parce que je pensais qu'elle pouvait
nous unir alors qu'elle nous a divisés
au niveau européen j'ai agi en votre nom
pour que l'austérité puissent être enfin
terminée pour beaucoup de peuples et
j'ai fait en sorte que la grèce puisse
rester dans la zone euro parce que sinon
elle aurait éclaté cette zone euro
tellement elle était traversé de
tensions et de crise j'ai également
réguler la finance oui la finance et le
système bancaire parce que ce que
j'avais trouvé en 2012 et est source de
tous les risques
voilà ce que j'ai fait point ce que
j'assume devant vous en revendiquant les
avancées en reconnaissant les retards et
même en admettant certaines erreurs
parce que je porte un bilan et j'en
assume toute la responsabilité dans cinq
mois vous aurez mes chers compatriotes à
faire un choix pour notre pays
la droite vient de désigner son candidat
après une large consultation je respecte
la personne le parcours de françois
fillon
mais j'estime que le projet qu'il porte
mais en cause notre modèle social et nos
services publics sans aucun bénéfice
au contraire pour notre économie et avec
un risque d'aggravation des inégalités
quant à l'extrême droite elle nous
appelle au repli à la sortie de l'europe
et du monde et elle prend comme
référence ce qui vient de se produire
aux états unis je vous le dis maintenant
franchement le plus grand danger c'est
le protectionnisme c'est l'enfermement
et ce serait d'abord un désastre pour
les travailleurs francs
c'est en comme président de la
république je tiens d'abord à ce que le
travail en france puisse être soutenue
et valoriser plus que quiconque
mes chers compatriotes je mesure l'enjeu
de la période qui s'ouvre comme
président de la république je dois
diriger l'état jeu j'ai la
responsabilité d'assurer le
fonctionnement régulier de nos
institutions jusqu'au terme de mon
mandat est dans un contexte où la menace
terroriste n'a jamais été aussi élevé
comme socialiste parce que c'est
l'engagement de toute ma vie je ne peux
accepter je ne peux me résoudre même à
la dispersion de la gauche à son
éclatement
parce qu'elle priverait de tout espoir
de l'emporter face au au conservatisme
et pire encore face à l'extrémisme dans
ma part je ne suis animé que par
l'intérêt supérieur du pays
le pays depuis plus de quatre ans et
demi je les servies avec sincérité avec
honnêteté
l'expérience m'a apporté l'humilité qui
est indispensable à l'action publique et
face aux épreuves
j'ai pu avoir une capacité inépuisable
de résistance devant l'adversité mais le
pouvoir d'exercice du pouvoir les lieux
du pouvoir et les rites du pouvoir ne
m'ont jamais fait perdre ma lucidité ni
sur moi même ni sur la situation car je
dois agir et aujourd'hui je suis
conscient des risques que ferait courir
une démarche la mienne qui ne
rassemblerait pas l'agent largement
autour d'elle aussi j'ai décidé de ne
pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle au renouvellement donc de
mon mandat je tenais ici à vous en faire
part directement comme je m'y étais
engagé
au début du mois de décembre tel que je
l'avais moi même annoncé je le fais en
prenant toute ma responsabilité mais
aussi en en appelant à un sursaut
collectif et qui engage tous les
progressistes qui doivent s'unir dans
ces circonstances parce que ce qui est
en cause ce n'est pas une personne c'est
de l'avenir du pays
je ne veux pas que la france soit
exposée à des aventures qui serait
coûteuse et même dangereuse pour son
unité pour sa cohésion pour ses
équilibres sociaux voilà le message que
j'étais venu ici vous adresser dans les
mois qui viennent on de voir mon seul
devoir sera de continuer à diriger le
pays celui que vous m'avez confiées en
2012 en me consacrant pleinement et dans
le dénuement le plus total à la
république vive la république et vive la
france